hey francis do you want to keep your
online activity
private yes i don't want anyone to know
i secretly watch bbc comedy embarrassing
that's why you need surf shark vpn how
can shark surf
shut up surfshark is a virtual private
network available as an easy to use
app and browser extension that lets you
place your laptop or phone
anywhere in the world allowing you to
access the internet as if you were in
another country
this means i can access a whole host of
websites
that i wouldn't be able to access in the
uk not only that you can protect your
online identity by masking your true ip
address
with surfshark you can protect yourself
from data theft
tracking surveillance and commercial
targeting and it's
great value for money because one
surfshark account can be used on
multiple devices
so you can access problematic content
wherever you are
and by problematic content we do mean
trigonometry click the link below and
use our code
trigonometry to get 83 percent off plus
three extra months for free surfshark
also offers a 30-day money-back
guarantee
so there's no risk to trying it out for
yourself click the link below and use
our code
trigonometry to get 83 off
plus three extra months for free
when there was a sense that the range of
ideas was being narrowed
that made me feel that something very
important and eaten and precious to it
was at risk
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if
you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
our terrific guest today is a teacher
who is dismissed from
eaton over a controversial lecture well
nolan welcome to trigonometry
thank you for having me it's great to
have you on i've given you the brief
introduction and we'll get into the
story itself but before we get into it
just tell everybody a little bit about
who you are how are you where you are
and where do you work
out so
interesting question about how i ended
up where i am um
after studying english at university i
knew we wanted to be a teacher
so i just constantly been working in
school since then
mixture of schools so secondary modern
school in kent
and then other end of the spectrum which
is ethan
between that highgate school in london
for a few years as well
and i've always been very passionate
about the importance of balanced debate
in education open rigorous discussion
and it's because of that
that when i was asked to not only allow
the cancellation of a lecture
intended for a hot-button controversial
issues debating course at ethan
to be cancelled at eaton but also to
remove it from my private youtube
channel
that i am where i am now i ask questions
about why this debate couldn't be had
if not eaten why not allow people to
explore the issues online
in their free time especially because
i'd agreed
with eaton to put a disclaimer on the
channel
when i set it up saying it was nothing
to do with eaton's personal views
so i was a bit puzzled why students
weren't allowed to
practice the importance of independent
critical thought
at least in their own time if it wasn't
allowed at the college itself
yeah we'll get into the story itself but
we have a large international audience
as well
and most people even in this country
haven't been to eat and
i don't know if you've been teasing
friends yeah i went i thought they
[ __ ] loved me
um i have been to eden just as a visitor
and you i just want just tell everybody
a little bit about
what is it like what is this institution
about
you know who are some of the people that
it's produced what is the point of eaton
like
because i think that is actually an
important piece of this definitely
so it's got a long and very rich history
of debate
all boarding schools have a room in them
called debate
as testament to that there's also a
purpose-built debating
hall where often speakers who might be
no platformed elsewhere
such as george galloway jermaine greer
have come to speak and the boys have
engaged with their ideas
students also run their own societies
independent from normal lessons
and they might invite external speakers
could be sometimes
politicians or ceos or prominent authors
to come and stimulate the kind of
argument that the school is famous for
so when there was a sense that the range
of ideas was being narrowed
that made me feel that something very
important and eaten and precious to it
was uh at risk and so
you say it was something important and
precious and i agree with you
what were these issues that were
controversial that you were talking
about
well the course is the college's
flagship debating course
called perspectives and it is for boys
in lower sixth
so about 16 17 year olds
and the theme for this term was identity
so the idea is it might be to do with
sex for example
or race or class all the kind of issues
that
come under the umbrella of identity
politics you could argue
and obviously these are all
controversial topics in the media and
culture at large
so it's important for boys to be
engaging with them and over the last few
years what i've noticed is that
some of these were being treated in a
way that in my opinion was partisan
and schools have a duty to be
non-partisan in the presentation of
political topics
can i just stop you there what do you
mean by partisan
so one-sided so taking one particular
line
and not exposing students to consider
the strongest arguments from the
opposing
side as an example of that
one of the students was complaining that
he felt that
gender theory was being presented as
fact in pshe lessons
and i had found that in trying to
encourage
wider debate around that resources which
were described as
excellent were being blocked in case it
caused upset
now it's difficult to see why a resource
which on the one hand
person blocking says is excellent
shouldn't be allowed to go ahead for the
purpose of stimulating student
discussion
just because it might cause upset to
somebody
freedom of speech involves the freedom
to upset
and also the freedom to receive
information that might upset
so it goes to the heart of what
education is all about really
so you you created this lesson
right you then went to teach these
lessons
and then what happened well it's
important to give a bit of background
about
what creating the lesson involved so
i asked a few people senior to me would
this be a good idea for a topic
to talk about the concept of toxic
masculinity and
patriarchy in a way that isn't often
touched on and he said that would be
interesting
good to stimulate debate so then i did
some reading
made sure everything in the lecture was
referenced fully because i wanted to
keep it to a high standard which is what
eating boys expect
and honoring the academic prestige and
scholarship of the institution
so there are over over 40 academic
references in the lecture
places like oxford cambridge harvard
yale
so i wanted to give the boys a fairly
heavyweight reading list to go and
pursue in their own time
the expectation was that they would uh
disagree with the lecture
on perspectives every single lecture is
scrutinized and boys are encouraged to
do that so the idea isn't that you just
listen and sit there and say
what lovely points i agree completely
the teachers
ask the students to pick it apart
so this would be a good opportunity for
them i felt to be able to try
out some of the ideas they'd been
hearing about patriarchy is
in its entirety a social construct
involving the oppression of women by men
but after i produced a video
the request came through to upload it
onto the college's
internal intranet system which is what
is
normally done when you distribute
resources so
i agreed to do that it was sent around
to
the teachers on the perspectives course
and before it was ever shown to students
the complaint came in
saying that according to the complainant
merely to allow
students to critically discuss this
amongst themselves
would place that member of staff in a
hostile environment
now to me that was something very
different from saying
for example that particular teacher
didn't want to have a discussion with me
or a debate with me on stage about him
i had asked for that would anybody like
to present alongside with me or give a
live
counter balance as i'm making points
nobody wanted to do that
that was disappointing but what was more
disappointing was that
the boys themselves weren't allowed to
think for themselves
about the material um and what what was
it
that you were presenting as this
challenging
course i i understand you weren't saying
this is the truth they're supposed to
push back against it and work out what
they think for themselves
but what was the con were you saying you
know what patriarchy is great and we
need to bring back more of it is that
what it was
well actually it was a presentation of
the the standard view
from evolutionary anthropology which is
that patriarchy is at least partly
rooted in biology
that's why we see it in other mammalian
species not just human beings
so it's difficult to see how it's purely
a social construct unless we've also
somehow socially constructed it in other
species as well which seems doubtful to
me
but this wasn't a particularly radical
position it's what
is the canonical position in the whole
body of mainstream science
it's just one that boys don't often hear
because you get the
view of the social scientists instead
which is purely social constructivism
so you uploaded it the complaint came
through
yep what happened next so lecture gets
cancelled
and i let the school know that it was
already
before the complaint had come in on my
personal youtube channel as well
with the agreed disclaimer now why did i
even have a youtube channel
why did i put that particular lecture
online well eaton is a
charity and it aims at providing
educational public benefit
and one of the things i was doing with
the youtube channel was just uploading
some videos
on the set poems and texts for gcse
boards to help students in other
countries who might not have access
to in some cases high quality teaching
or had missed lessons through illness
things like that it's good to have extra
resources to help people out
i'm getting a lot of positive feedback
from kids in malaysia
africa all over the world saying thanks
you helped boost my grade
for my literature exam so that meant a
lot to me
i'd also noticed through running a
school for state school students during
my summer holiday at eaton
to help give them a push normally for
oxbridge application
a lot of students were coming in with
this in my opinion quite
myopic view about the application of
patriarchy theory to some
classic texts to the extent that even if
they hadn't read
some particular works they almost
already knew what it was about because
everything is just about patriarchy it's
all just
men oppressing women now there's some
truth to that
but it's also the case that you should
think about things
on purpose in a way to challenge your
ideas so i thought
it would be good to get people trying to
undermine their own viewpoints if that's
what they're so entrenched in
so a video to shake them out of it okay
some people watching this
might be thinking well what will was
actually doing is he was trying to sneak
his particular opinion about this
under the guise of creating debate is
there some truth to that are you
quite strongly against the idea of the
patriarchy being you know
about oppressing women and women have
been historically oppressed and all of
that or
what do you have a personal view on it
well the video overlaps with my own
views
and if you look at the conclusion to the
video the main points
which is that men have traditionally
been valued for
procreating and then providing for women
and children protecting them
i think those are all fairly solid basic
family values
um there's also the message that
masculinity because of those three
traditional values
is essentially the antithesis of
pedophilia i don't think that's
particularly controversial either
there is overlap i would say the video
is slightly more hardline darwinian than
my own view of culture and society
but darwinism something the boys cover
in science lessons
why not see it brought to life with a
couple of examples from history and
video clips and quotations from poems
and books
were you not worried will because you'd
already had one complaint
against you against it you weren't
allowed to teach this course
were you not slightly worried about
uploading it to a youtube channel to the
public
which could be construed let's be fair
as a two fingers up to your employers
well it was already on youtube before i
even received the complaint
and once i heard that the lecture was
cancelled at eaton
i thought i'd better leave this thing up
unless i'm given a really good reason to
take it down
because there's going to be an
investigation into this and i'd like
people to see
what i'm being investigated for and i'm
thankful i did leave it up because
if you heard that someone had been
sacked for a video and then
you're wondering what might have been in
that could lead to some questions but
most people can go away and watch it and
think all right there are some punchy
points
but nothing that extremely intelligent
sixth formers
wouldn't be expected to engage with
sensibly
so you did it and then what happened
well
in the end after saying if you tell me
what's wrong with the video i'm happy to
edit out particular bits
i think it should go ahead i think it
honors our tradition of debate
and getting no response about any
particular bits that were problematic
it was just the entire thing had to come
down i was given the ultimatum
of take it down and then you'll be
investigated without being suspended or
if you leave it up
you'll be suspended and investigated so
i felt that
given that the investigation was
happening i was going to leave it up
because i didn't feel there's anything
wrong with the video
and uh then suspended from the college
while the investigation was ongoing
and then after a long process of appeal
during which there was a large
open letter set up by the students
signed by nearly 3 000 people
saying that we feel this debate should
have gone ahead uh i was dismissed
what i find strange is that
if the ideas you were presenting were
controversial
but they're part of this debating thing
that you do
at the school i find it very odd that
they just wouldn't find someone who
would
present a counter narrative do you have
any sense of
why the school fell did you have like
other complaints about you in the past
were people
you know upset with you over something
else no so this is one of the things
that
i find chilling about it is that my
disciplinary record
up until now has been perfect and it's
held in
quite high regard as a teacher by
parents and students and by colleagues
as well
so something about this particular video
really hit a nerve and my thought is
that perhaps it is a
traditional defense of masculinity at an
all-boys school
and i think all boys environment
increasingly nowadays is quite
sensitive and nervous about that almost
embarrassed to be an all-boys
institution
but there's a funny irony about that
because why are you one then
uh if everybody working there wants to
push this viewpoint that there's
something terrible about masculinity
why are you running an institution which
discriminate discriminates against girls
at the point of entry
i mean it's you know it's a very very
interesting point that you made
so the thing that i find
really really worrying about this is
that what it is saying
is that some viewpoints are just not
acceptable
it's not even that we can't even you
know support them
we can't even say them what do you think
that has for education
what are the impacts of this well for
one thing
it is not in the spirit of the actual
government legislation
the equality act which was initially
what the college
claimed that i'd breached
specifically excludes curriculum content
so this means that teachers are free in
theory
to discuss with classes any ideas no
matter how
controversial but the argument was that
although this might apply
to students so students are exempt if
they make a complaint
that they think that being asked to
explore particular material
uh constitutes harassment or
discrimination
members of staff aren't exempt
now if you think what kind of precedent
that sets
uh you can reduce it to absurdity so
let's say that
a particular teacher feels like being
asked to allow students to discuss
othello or to kill a mockingbird creates
a hostile environment
well that's harassment then and that
text has to go
and once you start down that route of
one person being offended
by being asked to allow students to
study curriculum material
it's difficult to see where you end and
you were talking before that you felt
the job was disappearing before your
very eyes
i don't mean to misquote you i think
that's what you said yeah
that's part that what you've just said
is part of it what else do you mean by
that
well i went into education into eton in
particular
because i like the excitement of
rigorous discussion
of debate i like challenging not just
other people's viewpoints but my own as
well
and this is why free speech is so so
valuable because it
enables that kind of discussion that
means that the rough edges can be taken
off ideas
and one question people often have is
well do you think everything in the
video is
completely true the whole point is that
i'm not actually really sure and the
discussion should be had so we can all
learn more from it
like the proverb says the pearl is
formed by abrasion
we need the marketplace of ideas to be
able to
actually find out which ones stand
attest to that kind of conflict
that makes sense and
i don't remember exactly but i remember
reading something from a parent
at the school who'd made a few comments
about the general atmosphere and and
particularly the leadership
what was it like working at eaton and
what was the overall sense around some
of these issues
it's been described by other members of
staff as a
stifling mono culture and the idea is
that
although we're not told explicitly what
kind of viewpoints might not be allowed
people know and they will tend to
self-censor
when a hot topic comes up you know what
the particular viewpoint you're supposed
to take on it is
otherwise you might find yourself in
similar situations who i am now
and what is the monoculture if you were
to summarize it
particular strands you could pick out
would probably be what you see
elsewhere in institutions that are given
in my opinion a fairly craven
response to this encroaching council
culture
so students would be unlikely to hear
for example
any kind of counter arguments to the
viewpoints
that characterize the black lives matter
movement unlikely to hear any kind of
counter-arguments to the view that
trans women are women for example
unlikely to hear any counter-arguments
in fact the one i tried to give was just
cancelled to the idea that
the fundamental relationship between men
and women is one of
men oppressing women as something called
the patriarch is a social construct
it's quite ironic really that a lot of
these views
are espoused by the left and yet eaton
is the most elitist institution
arguably in the country isn't it isn't
it isn't there something in congress
about this
interesting question and i do think that
one of the reasons eaton is so
sensitive about this and didn't even
want
boys to be seen to have the opportunity
to
to hear these views and maybe even say
why they were wrong
is that there's this sense that
because it sees him it's always worried
that someone's going to
come at it with those kind of claims
about being too elitist
so it's deliberately gone for the exact
kind of views
as the the branding that it thinks will
stop people being able to say that
so go further left in case people think
that you are
too far on the right i find that really
odd because as i
you know i'm from russia if i said to
someone
in russia in the far east of russia
never doesn't speak english
never seen foreign news whatever eaton
people would instantly know what it's
about
they would associate as the place which
produces
the great prime ministers the generals
the the the
boris johnson
the the people who really shape the
destiny of britain
and have shaped for for centuries
to to think i think it was a shock to a
lot of people
that an institution of that caliber
had been as captured as it clearly has
been according to
to your view uh by this mentality
it's quite a shock to a lot of people
did you find it
having worked elsewhere did did you find
that culture strange
well i think there's a bit of a divide
there between the way
the boys still want to operate and the
way
some members of staff want the place to
go
i think the boys by and large very much
still in favor
of the tradition of debate and most of
them wanted this talk to go ahead they
tried to invite
interesting sometimes controversial
speakers what we're seeing more and more
is that
that's getting shut down and the overton
window is moving because of
the demands of some members of staff i i
find that very odd
not least because the boys presumably
have internet access right
they do so they could watch our
interview with posey parker or
another conversation so it's not like
they're going to be insulated from these
ideas
so to me not allowing a lecture or
talker to be in a debate
is not really about protecting the boys
from quote-unquote bad ideas it's about
protecting the reputation of the
institution
would you agree with that i think one of
the main fears about
my particular lecture being on youtube
even with the disclaimer
was that it would somehow bring eaton
into disrepute now given that its
reputation
is for debate discussion and
as part of its aims it actually says
that we aim at
promoting independent broad-based
critical thought
it's difficult to see how just having a
debate can bring you into disrepute
but of course it's really about the
branding
it's not about the reputation for debate
at all but isn't it also as well
i mean let's be honest this to me
screams of weak leadership
from the head teacher because surely as
a head
your job is to say look this is what
we're going to do
this is our tradition and if you don't
like it and if you get upset
well number one you're entitled to do
that but you're not going to dictate
what can and can't be taught or said in
the college surely
i think there is an institutional loss
of nerve
involved and i think the leadership
should have given a more robust
response to the threat posed by
one person saying this whole debate has
to stop because it makes me feel sad
the boys should have been allowed to go
ahead with it and
you we see this right the way through
education don't we really it's not just
in eaton we see it at universities
um i think it's established
fairly well now that universities
are supporting this kind of council
culture because
there's about 10 of people who are
strongly in favor of it
if the academic gives a viewpoint that
is offensive or controversial
then they should be sacked and then the
majority of people
even if they weren't strongly opposed
that view um
quite happy just to watch it go along
and you get the same people especially
these elite schools like
eaton coming out of that university
environment and perpetuating the same
kind of culture
in the schools so it's that trickle-down
effect just as the ideas
tend to start in universities and then
they slowly percolate in secondary
schools
i think we're seeing the same kind of
institutional shift as well
and i'm curious why you felt strongly
enough because i imagined
i don't know but i imagine for a teacher
working at eaton
is the pinnacle of your career i would
have thought
right so you've given up quite a bit to
make this stand
why did you do that well it comes back
to the
comment that i made earlier about
feeling that i didn't really have a lot
to lose
because the job had already changed so
fundamentally
from what it was when i applied for it
and
what was important to me about it was
really wrapped up
in this whole dispute so if we're not
going to do
the exciting critical discussion on the
full range of topics
even if some of it is offensive to some
people then
that sucks a lot of the fun out of what
i feel is valuable about the job
and to be honest i think it also goes to
the heart of what has traditionally been
the essence of a western liberal
education
all the way back to socrates with the
starting point that
we're not really sure i know that much
actually and we should be very careful
and critical in how we
engage with each other so to say that
one particular
argument expressed in a lecture is just
not worth hearing whatsoever
as if you know for sure that there's no
truth in it
there's a real challenge to that and it
was best expressed by
john stuart mill in on liberty saying
that it's very rare
in the course of human affairs that one
side is completely right
and the other is completely wrong and
that's why it's so essential
that we have that give and take it's
vital that we have this giving
give-and-take i'll be honest with you
when i was reading about your case i was
i was completely horrified because i
think if you've been in education you
can see
the way it's going you can see the way
it's moving it's not just your case
we've seen batley grammar school
with what happened their refusal to
stand up for a teacher
when they were again when they were
talking about controversial issues
do you think we've now reached a point
where that battle is actually lost
and do you think as eric kaufman who we
had sitting in your seat said that what
we need is government intervention at
this point
in universities but probably also in
schools as well yeah i
i know there are people who who argue
that it's lost
um jordan peterson is saying now
send your kids to trade school i don't
think it's maybe that extreme i think
the u.s has gone further than we have
i think there's still a chance to turn
things around in the uk
and the reason this particular point of
principle meant a lot to me
is that it's never been litigated so the
equality act has never been used in this
way before
so when i found out that this was both a
novel
and activist interpretation of the
equality act
no teacher has ever fallen foul of this
idea of
curriculum content being fined for
students but not for staff
i thought it was one that would be worth
pushing because so much is at stake
in the spirit of of this uh abrasion in
order to create better understanding
let me try try and imagine some counter
points i'll be honest it's not easy for
me
because i agree with almost everything
you've said but if i
try surely there are certain things that
should not be taught in school would we
agree with that
well you want to think about the fact
that curriculum content
is excluded by law so that would seem to
give a kind of carte blanche
but nobody actually really thinks that
it's got to be age-appropriate
you've got to have it in the correct
kind of context but the thing for me is
if the flagship debating course
of one of the country's leading
educational institutions which has a
debating hall and every boarding house
has a debate room in it in it
isn't the appropriate context then what
is i
agreed um and
i mean i'll give you another i'm really
struggling here
i would say good counter so you
sometimes get people who say look i'm
all for free speech but
it's different in schools teachers are
in a position of authority
and you have to be very careful about
what ideas you were being seen to give
the model of approval to
yeah what would your response be to that
i can think of one well i mean in this
case it's a debate
right and you're encouraging the kids to
push back and to work out
what the truth is for themselves so
you're not presenting them with this as
fact
you're saying when you go out into the
big bad world and by the way it's going
to be a year from now or two years from
now
right you're going to be confronted by
these ideas and it's helpful to you to
have actually thought about them before
and consider them and rejected elements
of them
so that you know what you bloody think
yeah knowing what you think through
engaging with the other side is
certainly
a very strong justification for being
challenged
i think it also if you really dig down
to what that objection
is driving at is okay so there are some
dangerous ideas are there
um which are the viewpoints that we must
be very careful that teachers aren't
being seen to personally uphold
and once you ask that kind of question
and
get those ideas explicitly laid out then
i think what you'll find is it starts to
move towards very much the
the woke direction those are the
official viewpoints that
institutions are willing to give the
seal of approval to
and teachers who question them or want
boys to
at least consider arguments for and
against uh are seen as
undermining the institutional project
well i wonder
no i'm a big fan of history how do you
teach the history of world war
ii without educating boys about the
motivating factors behind
nazism for example right and in order to
to teach them that
they have to understand right now by
teaching them about adolf hitler you're
not approving of him
right but if you if you were to present
a a
lecture on how the nazis came to the
viewpoints that they did
i suppose in this case it could be seen
by somebody as
a hostile environment because you know
as my
great grandparents died in the holocaust
well i could claim it's a hostile
environment for me
so i this is a slippery slope that i
think goes
to hell very very quickly exactly taking
that example you could have a
history teacher who by being asked to
allow
students to study my camp and critically
evaluate its arguments says hostile
environment for me i refuse to
teach this book and the students won't
be studying either
so that's why the fact that it's a
teacher saying it's offensive to that
particular teacher to let
students weigh up the pros and cons of
the arguments is really what the heart
of this is
it's not students saying we think it's
offensive the government advice is clear
there it doesn't matter if you think
it's offensive
but it's this claim that that only
applies to students not staff
so then whose personal sense of offense
gets to determine what curriculum
content is
because i'd be willing to bet a lot of
money on the fact that
if i took offense to a forceful
presentation of patriarchy as merely a
social
construct as offensive to to me as a man
i don't think that would achieve very
much i'd love to see that
straight white male teacher but this is
the asymmetry right yeah i'm i'm not
trying to shut down anybody's views i
think they should all be heard and the
more the better
because it gives people more arguments
to get their teeth into yeah and why is
there that asymmetry
it seems to be a kind of uh
i think it's ultimately a kind of lack
of belief
in in reason and debate itself it's also
lack of belief in your own argument
i feel they feel that the arguments are
weak
and the only way to get them to be
embedded in all these institutions is
that no one ever gets to challenge them
i think that's a lot of it i honestly do
i think that is certainly an important
factor
but remember that one of the
main tenets of post-modernism is
actually that
truth itself is a kind of social
construct
now you can explode that fairly quickly
by saying well
so is it true there's no truth
and then it starts to fall apart yeah so
it's necessarily false
but if you honestly don't believe there
is such a thing as truth
then why have the debate if it's all
just about power
then just stop the narrative you don't
like being heard and reduce its power
so i think there's that element to it as
well isn't it also part of it as well is
that
even i don't know how old you are well
35
you're 35 right so but if you remember
when we grew up
our generation right i'm playing age 35
you're 28 years
old i'm nearly 40. it's i'm fine with it
anyone's very fine with it i'm very fine
with it but there was a rough and tumble
aspect to our childhood
that i think being a teacher is going to
make me sound old has been
lost from our society we want to wrap
kids up in cotton wool we want to
protect them
and that may be they want to protect
them from physical harm but we also want
to protect them from psychological harm
do you think that's part of it as well
well i don't think anybody at least at
the outset was
trying to protect kids from any kind of
psychological harm it was an adult
saying i can't possibly cope with
allowing kids to discuss this
for me one of the markers of adulthood
is actually being willing to
seek out intellectual and emotional
challenge
and i think people [ __ ] their own
development if they don't deliberately
seek that out because you just stay in
your comfort zone continually
that's seen as a bad thing in many walks
of life i think in
intellectual life it should be the same
you should be taking sides against
yourself
in order to find out fully what you
really think if you do
say that kids always need to be kept
safe then the counter argument would be
just as with uh avoidance
um with anxiety actually entrenching
anxiety i think it just means that the
range of ideas you're willing to explore
and able to explore
uh narrows and narrows and narrows and
what do you think is
look i'll be honest with you uh my wife
and i are talking about having kids and
this is something that terrifies me
because you you bring a child into the
world
you you raise them for six or seven
years and then you send them off
to an institution that's going to
indoctrinate them with a bunch of crap
what what if if you're a young parent of
young kids or you're thinking about
what's the answer to this why do you
what do you do
well there are certainly some parents
and people in the old italian community
who felt the same way and some of the
emails of support that came in for me
were quite heartbreaking to read there
were people saying
this man needs to be reinstated or i'll
never be proud to be an old italian
again
there are parents saying that they
hadn't expected to
send their kids there for this and they
thought that that
tradition of debate and the aims of
independent critical thought and
broad-based discussion really meant what
they said on the tin
so the reason i think i gathered so much
support from the community is that
people do think there is something
really precious here that's at risk
and uh if you've got kids coming to the
world i've got five
a sixth one coming soon i think it
involves
more people having to actually
make a stand and not tolerate what's
being done to the education system
because a lot of people disagree with it
but just won't say anything
hey constantine how are you feeling good
and your mental health i'm from russia
we don't have mental health
well in the civilized world we talk
about our mental health
and how we're feeling about our place in
the universe
in the words of my uncle vlad that is
why we will crush you
well he's two months away from a
breakdown for the rest of us
there's a number one mental wellness app
called calm
that helps you to negotiate the tricky
modern world
it's okay to need help sometimes and
calm can provide support
karma's been really useful for me you
can clear your head with guided daily
meditations
improve your focus with calms curated
music tracks
and drift off to dreamland with calms
imaginative sleep stories
narrated by soothing voices like killian
murphy
and stephen fry oh killian save me
man up drink vodka feel better if you go
to calm.com
trigger you'll get a limited time offer
of 40 percent off
a calm premium subscription which
includes hundreds of hours of
programming
and new content is added every week over
1 million people
around the world use calm to take care
of their minds
yes trigonometry fans get special
limited time promotion 40
off premium subscription take advantage
of this amazing offer go to cam.com
forward slash trigger
for 40 off unlimited access to calm
entire library that's com.com
forward slash trigger
and do you think a lot of it is this
monoculture
but also as well do you do you think the
unions are giving enough support
to teachers who have the different views
or do you think like in the case that we
saw with partly grammar school
where the neu did nothing i think that
was a weak response
more needs to be done all levels
so i think the government needs to keep
an eye on what is happening
in secondary schools there's been
studies on
how free speech is imperiled at
university level
and in theory at least six form
education colleges are supposed to be
having particular
regard for the importance of freedom of
speech and
it's easy for institutions to make
excuses and say well yes we do believe
in freedom of speech but
here it was about the reputational risk
for example
or we also have obligations to the
particular member of staff who
complained
but i think ultimately that is just
having a confused hierarchy
because freedom of speech needs to come
first
yeah and it seems that it's rapidly
evaporating from our schools do you
think it's worse in the private sector
because they want to be seen to be woke
because they want to be seen to be more
moral because the fact is you know
this is a fee-paying environment
do you think the state sector is as bad
uh from what i've heard
i don't think the state sector is quite
as bad
um i think there's this peculiar tension
between
how private schools are traditionally
seen and what it's actually like to work
in them
nowadays you can see this happening in
the states as well so the more elite the
institution the more likely it is
to have gone the whole hog with the woke
viewpoint um
partly that's about concern that people
will
criticize them if they don't um partly
as the uh
the medieval theologians used to say the
the corruption of the best
becomes the worst so the more complex i
think the more elite the institution
the the worse it is when it goes wrong
and what do you think the impact of this
will be
over time where essentially the people
who go to the best schools particularly
but everybody really
is being indoctrinated with this
particular mindset
over time what does that lead to
in your opinion well the the boys
lettering supported me
said that it erases much
of what has traditionally constituted a
liberal education
uh i think the line they used was uh
young men and their ideas are formed
through
conflict so we want people to be
robust intellectually and emotionally
when they leave these institutions and
go on to be
in the case of eaton certainly leading
figures in all kinds of areas of
public life and business if anyone
thinks that they're somehow going to
have an easy right
where people tiptoe around their
feelings when they leave eating i think
they're going to be
very uh severely disappointed
it does feel and look maybe it's just me
maybe it's you know i've got my
conspiracy hat on do you sometimes feel
like
it's starting to feel like an attack on
masculinity almost
well if you if you watch the video and
ask yourself what kind of viewpoints
here are
really problematic is it the idea that
some of the traits that are now called
toxically masculine
i think according to the america
american psychological association it's
uh stoicism
dominance aggression
competitiveness and what i did just to
encourage looking at those from a new
angle in the video would say that well
actually
men have been valued for these things
traditionally in many societies and
cultures across history
you don't get many cultures which value
men who are cowards for example
now why is that a lot of this stems from
war and the necessity of self-defense
and the protector role
and that is rooted in biological
essentialism
so the difference is between men and
women which i think people are
uncomfortable
talking about now because they're seen
as social constructs
maybe they do have real consequences for
how societies are organized
we talk a lot about patriarchy as a
social construct but
anthropologists haven't discovered a
single genuine matriarchy
now why is that that's a topic for
people to discuss
but to say that the view of masculinity
as being partly rooted in the protector
role and providing for women and
children
as being beyond the pale for discussion
i think that's quite bizarre
do you think we're struggling as as as a
culture and a society to adjust to the
fact that
our roles have changed technology the
pill
the creation of all sorts of domestic
appliances
other technological changes now mean
that
basically men in that conception
are less necessary let's say there's
less of a need for men to protect
there's
women can earn their own living in the
world you know they're not
forced to be stuck at home looking after
children because we have the ability now
to sort of
outsource that mostly to technology and
stuff like that and
we are as a society feeling our way
through
these changes and that is where a lot of
the
the tension comes from do you do you see
what i'm saying yeah
so i think that would have been one of
the topics that would have been great to
discuss
after the video so thanks for bringing
it up
um very interesting the
thing that really addresses i feel is
that our
biology hasn't really changed much um
certainly not in a fundamental way
since that of our stone age ancestors so
yeah it seems easy to say well men don't
need to be protective anymore
but the physical differences between men
and women are still there
and good luck to any guy who
hides behind his girlfriend if the two
of them get mugged walking down the
street
i think the expectation of what the
traditional roles are
still persists if we were getting that
height behind you
i'd promise you that you just looked at
him and went yes
that is exactly how we should be but i
guess what i'm getting at is
this whole conversation i feel is become
so
toxic because as you said there's so
many like don't go there don't look
there don't touch that don't open that
box don't
and why can't we have this conversation
in in a
in a robust way but also in a sensitive
way we can also have it that way too
like
let's look at how society has changed
yes men are less
we need to be less physically defensive
now
and women can earn their own way like
what's the way we manage that as a
society what a
do do we you know if you are of the
other point of view and you think well
maybe men should have more maternity
leave so that they can look after kids
if that's what you believe right
like let's have that conversation why
why do we have to
shut down why do we have to cut things
off why can't we just have
the talk well what if it's about
ultimately
prioritizing emotional safety over any
form of intellectual challenge
what if that's the thing that we really
need to think about
is it worth anyone ever getting upset
at the risk of
getting a complaint and possible legal
action
being launched or should we go ahead
because we prioritize
intellectual discussion and rational
argument
do you not find it ironic though will
that this society
is the safest society there's ever been
and yet all we seem to talk about is
keeping people safe
there's a certain irony there isn't
there yeah this is
a case that's full of ironies so one of
the views in the video is that men have
traditionally been valued for protecting
women and children
and that view that women needed
protecting was apparently
extremely offensive and yet the
headmaster stepped in to protect
the complainant from having to face the
dangerous video
so there's protection running right the
way through this
so arguably it proves the video's point
and there's also another element to this
and you get this a lot with comedy where
this person who complained presumably
wasn't
required to attend the lecture were they
well it would have been due to covid uh
supervising boys in a room while they
watched the lecture
right and then supervising boys
critically discuss it amongst themselves
so chairing a discussion i see
but no one's being kind of called out
and targeted so could this person have
asked
not to be the person who led this chair
this discussion could they've been
replaced by someone else
i don't see why not right so if they
felt that it would be a hostile
environment for them surely the solution
would have been for them to remove
themselves from that situation
rather than to deprive the the students
of the opportunity to hear the argument
yeah exactly and also leaving it on
youtube right no one has to
watch a video on that it's the same with
comedy like you get
you get a comedian that does a routine
in a comedy club where people enjoy it
or
some people enjoy it and then that gets
played on breakfast television or that
gets referenced on breakfast television
as if the comedian had walked onto the
set of good morning britain at seven in
the morning
and done a you know a pedo gag or
whatever it might be
and and this is someone who's
deliberately taking
something out of a context into a
different situation
well i think it can be uh
easy to interpret it as being merely
about taking offense sometimes taking
offense can be a form of aggression
and i think what it's really about is
not wanting anybody to hear the
viewpoints at all yeah in case they
might believe them because
they're not ones that that particular
person wants aired
this goes back to what kyle popper was
explaining in the open society
and its enemies about one of the marks
of intolerance being the refusal to
entertain
rational discussion so just say we're
not going to do this at all
and we're not going to allow people to
hear it either and at that point
you start to wonder how different woke
tears
are from brown shirts boots stomping
i mean it's a good point it's a good
point man i wanna
like i've increasingly tried to engage
in counter arguments on our show i'm
really struggling here i really am it
just
it just seems like such an obvious thing
that young men or boys
should be taught to think and to engage
with different arguments
as young girls should be young people of
all of all [ __ ] hell
anyway uh young people should be
engaging with different arguments it's
really as simple as that and
i just find this whole my story
mind-boggling i think the vast majority
of the public
do you know i don't think this point of
view is widely shared in society
and yet it's the dominant one it's a
dominant one in our culture how did that
happen
well so we know that it's well
established that
universities in particular are very much
dominated by
this particular view of culture and very
few academics are willing to oppose it
i don't think academics and teachers as
a as a group
generally are famous for their for their
courage and their willingness to make
stands on things
but even if it is the case that it's
dominated by this viewpoint well how did
that happen i think part of it goes back
to
um plato's idea of philosopher kings
and the intellectuals know best and it's
the case that
anybody wanting to hear certain
viewpoints
really doesn't know what's good for them
and they should trust the people who
do know what's best and that includes
saying what you're allowed to hear
what you're allowed to think about and
that's
quite chilling i think it is very very
chilling and
it's not only what happens to people but
what that happens what do you think is
going to be the long-term effects of
this
if we don't make a stand if more people
don't stand up and say this is
unacceptable
i think what you'll see is more and more
texts getting removed
from the curriculum uh i was in a
meeting where it was suggested that we
need to have
fewer dead white males on the english
reading list
so shakespeare better be careful we've
seen that in many
u.s schools so that's one very worrying
consequence i think another is that
you'll get people who are passionate
about ideas
and that teaching means a lot to not
wanting to pursue
careers in teaching we see that in
academia already
people not wanting to undertake phd
research because they know that i like
to get funding for their particular
topics
so i think there's a lot at stake and
some of the emails of support to me were
saying they felt that
eaton's response had brought not only
eaton to disrepute but
british education abroad i think that's
definitely happening yeah
absolutely that is definitely deaf and
if i were a parent who could afford to
send their kids to eden now
i mean i don't know where else i'd send
them but i certainly wouldn't send them
to eaton do you know what i mean
it's like i think it has damaged the
reputation of the school
quite considerably actually um
so what's next for you well at the
moment
i've got a lot going on with the legal
action against the college
but are you hoping to be reinstated
i think there's a lot of people in the
old italian community
and some of the donors supporting me
students and parents who would like to
see
reinstatement which they consider would
be a just outcome
we'll see what the response is i
definitely do
miss the job i miss the classroom and
it was a pleasure working there and i
think there's a lot of good people still
there
who do want to fight back against this
but aren't quite sure how
and they don't want to end up in the
position i'm in now
and to anybody else working at similar
schools whether in britain or in the us
i would just say was it the career that
you
envisioned for yourself having to
self-censor for
20 years or so and if it is
that you're worried about the
consequences for your for your family or
your kids if you're a family man like me
then think what kind of culture you were
contributing to by being silent and not
pushing back when your own kids are at
school when they grow up
i think people do need to actually put
things on the line
for us to be able to turn anything
around i think about that a lot man
i think about you know your kids
watching you i think you'll be very
proud
and i think that probably to you is much
more precious than
whatever job you had or whatever else so
yeah
the people had some comments like why
did he do this with a family i did it
because i got a family
and my kids are experiencing the same
thing at school my daughter's 15
and she knows what's happening and when
the request came through to delete it
off youtube as well
i asked my wife what should we do here
if i don't
take this down this could turn ugly
quite fast
and she said i know how important this
is to you
and i don't want to see you miserable
working there
not being able to speak your mind and
have the kind of debates you want with
the students
so let's do it and it meant a lot to me
that
she was behind me was there any point
where you regretted it where you think
i can't i didn't i i wish i could row
back now
no i don't think so it's so much support
from people
and also it's about something so
important i can't imagine myself
still working there creating resources
that get blocked in case someone gets
upset
and the thing that really did it for me
was that some of the material coming out
about
black lives matter in the wake of george
floyd's death
was so one-sided and i wanted to share a
video by
thomas salt talking about the history of
black communities
talking about the history of slavery and
the fact that it's a universal human
institution and what's unique about the
british empire is it ended it
and uh that was blocked so that's a
surprise
i guess uh thomas soul wasn't the right
kind of black voice yes yeah and we've
got plenty of them on the show there's a
whole wall of pictures behind you
yeah that's it resources from candace
owens blocked as well so to have
uh these usually male
upper-class white academics blocking
voices like candace owens is that's not
right
and thomas sol particularly listen man
thanks so much for coming on talking to
us we appreciate
it uh good on you i i've tried my best
to come up with counter arguments i feel
like i failed
uh that's because i really struggled to
see the other side in this conversation
i think
i've really enjoyed this interview
watching him fail by the way yeah yeah
right
it's a big counter argument that they
give is that teachers just aren't
allowed to give
videos like that one lectures like that
one so i've been referred to the
teaching regulation
agency potentially banning me from the
classroom for life
and uh we'll see what their response is
i think
that will send a very strong signal
either way to
other teachers about the direction of
travel for secondary schools
but to all the teachers who have emailed
me messages support all the parents all
the students
uh you're welcome uh well uh
on that note actually if people are
watching this and
do you need support with anything where
should people go to check out
the progress of your case and and
whatever else uh yeah that's uh
kind of you to mention that so on the
description of the youtube video there's
a link to
donorbox which is my crowdfunding to
support the legal cases
but other than that i would tell people
just to keep pushing for exciting
interesting debates
because i think that this stranglehold
will just keep
tightening unless people set the line
somewhere
i agree agreed will thank you so much
for coming on the show
we always end our interviews with one
question which is always what's the one
thing we're not talking about but we
really should be
i think the crisis of
masculinity especially in all boys
schools
needs to be addressed urgently i think
these institutions many of them
are embarrassed to exist and they need
to think hard about why that is
if you don't really believe in all boys
education then i think it's hypocritical
to be providing it
and people need to put boys in touch
with
the past and the traditions about what
it means to be a man
rather than rubbishing them and leaving
them with some of the main
pillars of their identity as one of the
eaton boys put it just crushed to dust
well thank you so much for coming on
guys we hope you've enjoyed this
wonderful episode if you want to check
out our episodes or our live stream
saying
always go out at 7 00 p.m uk time take
care and see you soon